i got a question about the walk out
with uh with the music like
i was so impressed when you had the
the song the queen the song by the the
rock band
yeah like you know like uh dude i got
goosebumps from that
what like what's the the lyric i
remember when on your walkout song it's
like i've
done this mistakes i've had
dude it was incredible the question is
are uh
are fighters allowed to just pick any
song they want do they have to license
the music
so we are not allowed to come out to
music
that has not been published by like
professional like label and stuff like
that
i think that's the way it works so at
before the ufc we would have all the
local kind of homies making your
your local your song or whatever and i
think copyright and lawsuits that people
wanted to get a piece of the
ufc and oh you guys played my song on
pay-per-view now i should get a cut and
all this type of stuff so dana white
just said hey you know
once they i think they play the fight
live when you come out that night and
then even reruns
on tv on television are always
but the more known music like queen is
going to be considerably more expensive
to license i wonder how that i wonder
how that even works yeah
you know i've never asked i've never
asked but the ufc i work with a woman
named heidi who works at the ufc office
she always does the customizations of
our songs and and they can
they got some hella djs that can cut up
any song any three or four or five songs
you want and
it did the walkout music is just such a
big deal in setting the tone for the
fight
yeah i try not to i'm not i try not to
be too superstitious
about you know music and little things
like that just just in case if something
doesn't go your way say
the music stops or the audio goes out or
whatever you're always able to get it on
no matter what state you know so right
okay yeah that makes sense to me
yeah i don't i don't hang on to the
music too closely but every once in a
while i'll try to put subliminal
messages
in in the song that i choose um but i
don't allow it to affect my mental state
yeah i just thought that queen that was
the only time you used that queen tune
right yeah i've used it a few times
i've used it maybe two or three times
since the first time
yeah but it's a relatively new thing
it's great i appreciate you
paying attention get ready this is gonna
be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of narly are we ready
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [ __ ] up
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off